une maladie sommeille en nous et le
monde comme la pile qui laisse un goût
amer pour notre arrière gauche elle est
en chacun de vous qui êtes assis à cette
table
ce n'est que lorsque nous connaissons
notre mal que nous pouvons espérer lui
trouver un remède
qu'en pensez vous manifestement il a
perdu la tête
c'est ce que nous pensons aussi
souhaitons que vous alliez en suisse ra
meunier monsieur pembroke parmi nous
nous proposons ici un traitement de
purification à l'abri des pressions du
monde moderne où conclure amené monsieur
pembroke avec vous ça pose un problème
c'est un patient par un prisonnier
vous êtes là pour la cure non d'ailleurs
j'allais repartir personne ne repart
jamais heureux de vous revoir monsieur
lecard tu signes de commotions
cérébrales système immunitaire affaibli
j'aimerais vous recommander un
traitement voyez cela comme une
purification de l'esprit autant que des
corps
chez certains patients cela provoque ont
des visions mais pas d'inquiétude
ce ne sont que les toxines
quitte le système
une terrible nouaceur russie
cela s'est passé il ya 200 ans
tout ça se produit aujourd'hui
dit que personne ne va pas jamais il
leur arrive quoi j'ai vu les corps
écoutez vous vous n'êtes pas bien
portant
vous essayez de me faire croire que juif
qu'est ce qu'ils vivent pas réparties de
la cure
y'a pas de pure
accepter le diagnostic
vous verrez
c'est merveilleux ici
[Musique]
belga
tl-s
toi elle est traînée
au secours
tous
du coup
je
ouf
oh
[Musique]